the impact that the fans here
in milwaukee have on the energy in this
ballpark and get these guys going and
they are excited
to be back at work here in milwaukee
woodruff making a second consecutive
opening day start he is
an ace in every sense of the word
woodruff ready to deal one two and a
line
shot oh what a catch how about that to
start the year
with a gem right away yep circle that
one
[Applause]
up to a late start in spring training
had some injuries
and check this catch out it's slicing
away from him and a
good dive perfectly time dive able to
haul it in that was a slider from
brandon woodruff
but a heck of a play to start the season
you got some guys in their 30s is
keeping them on the field keeping them
healthy and managing rocketball delhi's
talked about that finding his ways to
make sure that
he can give donaldson enough rest but
still make him effective and keep him on
the field
this ball hit hard and this one does hit
the gap in left center field
and donaldson oh who rounded first
and had a
skip in his step i don't know if he
slept
watkins is going to come out and just
get his gear
and my goodness he rifled the ball to
the gap and left center field and
there's concern right away about his
lower half
opening gay starter kenta maeda over his
career
has been good and as a minnesota twin
was even better
gets the knot as the opening day starter
he's made quite a few in japan this is
his first one
in the united states and he
gets a strikeout of wong a foul tip and
garber hangs on went away
and the 2-2 strike three called locked
up on his high slider
at 87 miles an hour hiro was looking for
something else phil maeda two batters in
two strikeouts
did he go yes he did a strikeout for
woodruff
a nasty slider that was on three pitches
as well
needed a quick start to this second
inning woodruff would
there's a swing at a miss woodruff with
back-to-back case that gives him three
so far
good start to this second inning making
quick work of buxton and garber
two on two out no score narvaez sets up
down and away and the one-two pitch is
in the dirt kicks away from narvaez
cave comes home he scores standing
twins take a one-nothing lead in a ball
that got away from narvaez that'll be a
wild pitch cenote down to second twins
lead one zip
circle change up down skipped
right in front of the plate the ground
narvaez it went to his right
cave read that scored easily standing
cenote a second
and now a 2-2 count walked and scored
sono at second
2-2 again to kepler
that's the center field and that'll die
for a hit sono
being waved around third he's coming
home and he'll score with kepler
delivering a clutch two out
rbi single and what is it it's it's
single it's the small ball
it's taking the extra bases it's doing
all those things it's two strike hitting
kepler looked like he might have the the
biggest exhale exhale we'll see from him
all year you know a lot of pressure on
himself he's one of those guys who
expects results and had a tough spring
but
it's all erased on opening day when
you're able to hit a ball right off the
end of the bat
now shaw a chance to do some damage
bottom of the third i think twins got
two in the top of this frame
three two two outs we'll do it again
another 3-2 pitch runners go
sean takes ball four oh that's a good
advantage
travis really good at that i mean that's
a veteran guy
knows his strike zone not a deer in the
headlights type of at-bat
that's when you want a veteran at the
plate 60 pitches 35 of them this inning
for maeda
ground ball to third arise sets and
fires and sonos able to keep a toe on
the bag
now you've got a contact hitter up there
you've got a guy who can hit singles a
guy who
can drive in runs cave on deck 3-2 pitch
in a line drive base hit into center
field rounding third
simmons heading home and the twins get
another
two out hit with two strikes to produce
a run this time from luis arize
that's huge on so many levels you know
you had a two nothing lead it was cut in
half in the last half inning a long
inning
maida was out there working for a long
time ari is doing his
best job of hitting with two strikes
it's incredible what he's able to do
look that's just such a simple swing
that's a
i'm not trying to hit this ball 400 feet
i'm just trying to make sure i put this
ball in play
it's all about the finish
just like that yeah ball seems to rise
as he gets the home plate
three balls two strikes on snow peralta
and he put a fastball by him well
because of the sliding on three and one
i mean ceno wasn't sure two on two outs
the one-two got him fastball upstairs
[Applause]
to the brewers with the bases loaded
duffy deals narvaez little jam shot left
field falling fast it is down
yellows will score and now winding it up
is shawn he's going to be out by a
mile at the plate hey yikes
he got thrown out by a ton that's a big
out it would have been
bases loaded one out instead first and
second
two outs on a perfect throw from cave
and
perfect throw by kade to get him by ten
feet
and he got him fouled him up with a
fastball rock that was
down the middle and puts it right by
cruz
no kidding the one-two he got him a
strikeout for peralta
cave couldn't pull the trigger well you
never know when
the moment of the game happens
[Applause]
this feels like one of those moments
right now
brewers down a run sixth inning
and the dangerous snow up there with the
bases loaded
three and two the count runners take off
and a swing
and a miss he struck him out
[Applause]
he threw on the spinner
[Applause]
here's byron big guy big run at second
base right now byron over two of the
walk in a stolen base he swings and
launches
high and deep to left center beckett
goes deep it goes and gone
buckston a long home run to left center
field
the first bumba of 2021 comes from byron
buxton
and the twins open up a three-run lead
5-2 twins in the seventh
450 feet a long
long blast for byron all smiles inside
that third base dugout
and the twins lead by three as christian
yelled steps in
representing the tying run just the man
the brewers won
at the plate in a spot like this two on
one out
yelling in the right center way back
and over
coming in to score is wong
wow and the boys are alive kepler was
there on a line
shot could not make the play
a run is in it's 5-3 minnesota
yeah the brewer dugout thought it was a
tie game but
kepler just had it in and out of the
glove that'll be a single right
single they scored a shot by
yelits and now a base hit if it touches
the outfield grass
will tie the game yelachenhira ready to
run
and shaw in the right center a base hit
into the gap
a double on the first pitch boy how good
does that feel for travis
wow oh what a moment for a hand
on opening day oh the brewers bounce off
the mat and tie it up
[Applause]
a swing out of this hater 98
[Applause]
a hundred miles an hour i don't think
we've ever seen a hundred out of hindi
[Applause]
end of the game late at the short stop
position
and rc a big bouncing ball kate's coming
to the plate it's glove to throw home
he's safe the brewers win
oh a thriller on opening day 20 21
arcia with a chopper